tiendas de campaña y refugios
improvisados que terminaron como restos
calcinados es el campamento de memoria
el más grande de europa que da abrigo al
menos tres 100.000 refugiados cuatro
veces por encima de su capacidad estos
migrantes se quedaron sin refugio la
mayoría terminaron pasando la noche al
lado de la autopista en el mismo suelo
porque el incendio comenzó una noche con
varios afectados intentando respetar lo
poco que podían otros miraban resignados
como ardía su refugio mi hogar mi ropa
están destruidos todo está destruido
el incendio fue controlado pero antes de
las llamas se habían propagado con
rapidez lado de los fuertes vientos y
con la llanura que rodea el campo la
isla de lesbos se encuentra en estado de
emergencia el de tweeter la oficina del
primer ministro anunció una reunión
extraordinaria reunión interministerial
extraordinaria sobre memoria bajo la
dirección del primer ministro en la
mansión de máximos la primera
preocupación ahora son los millares de
refugiados que deben ser reubicados pero
también hay que aislar a aquellos que
están contagiados del nuevo coronavirus
antes del incendio había al menos 35
casos